hi
everyone welcome back so i'm going to go
a little bit more into depth
in this analysis of chaos as an
intermittently forced linear system
for some more advanced examples from the
real world
okay so just remember we have this
henkel alternative view of koopman this
havoc analysis the idea here is you have
a real system a complex chaotic system
you have
limited measurements a time series of
limited measurements of your system
you build up a hankel matrix by taking
time-shifted copies of this measurement
stacking them as rows of a ankle matrix
and if you take the singular value
decomposition
you get these eigen time delay
coordinates that you can then use
to get an embedded a delay embedding so
this delay embedded attractor
is diffiomorphic to the original lorenz
attractor
and what's cool is that this henkel
matrix the columns are all
spanned by the first dominant columns of
this
u matrix from the singular value
decomposition
and it turns out that this provides an
intrinsic
data-driven measurement system that's
invariant to the kutman operator okay so
we've shown that previously
and what that means is that in these
eigen time delay coordinates we actually
have some hope
of getting a linear model a linear
representation of the dynamics
and so what we do is we build this
linear regression model
from all of the v coordinates so v dot
equals this linear operator times v
where v
are these eigen time delay coordinates
now the last
row the the last time delay coordinate v
r is never
very well approximated by this linear
model so this last row is kind of a bad
fit
so instead we decide we're not going to
try to model that that's an
external forcing okay so we have our
first
r minus one delay coordinates is given
by
some linear model in the first r minus
one delay coordinates
plus some forcing from the vr
the arth or last time delay coordinate
and so plotting that for the lorentz
system you see again this intermittent
forcing in red that's this forcing
that's hard to model
but it's this internal sorry this
external forcing
you get this linear dynamics the model
prediction from these linear dynamics in
blue
gives you a very good reconstructed
attractor
and again you find that when this
intermittent forcing is large or
active um that's when this
system is about to switch lobes okay so
the
the bursting or the large intermittent
forcing is actually predictive
of lobe switching which is very neat
so we can apply this to tons of
different examples all of this code you
can download and try these for yourself
but right now we're going to zoom in on
a couple of the really physically
relevant systems of the earth's magnetic
field and the measles outbreak
so looking at the earth's magnetic field
is is kind of neat so
we're running a simulation based on uh
the work the work below and this is
basically a simulation
of the magnetohydrodynamic equations
that are
forced by you know turbulence inside the
earth's crust
it's very cool model this
numerical simulation can give you
the attractor switching in the earth's
magnetic field corresponding to field
reversal
okay so we've known for quite some time
that the earth's magnetic field on
geological time scales the north pole
sometimes actually flips
um and it's kind of hard to predict we'd
love to have a good prediction
of this we know by looking at the you
know the crust
that this has happened in the past and
so this is a very simple model
that describes this lobe switching so
you have two attractors
corresponding to the north pole kind of
this way and the south pole
and so these red trajectories correspond
to when the earth's magnetic field
flips okay so when you flip poles
that's this red trajectory here where
the forcing in our havoc model is active
and it's kind of neat that you also get
these these
trajectories that almost flip but then
they come back so there are times where
the earth's magnetic field
almost flips but it doesn't okay
according to this model at least
but that's kind of neat so
if we look in at the the time syste the
time history these eigen time delay
coordinates we have v1 this is our
dominant time
history and vr this is our external
forcing
and i'm plotting vr squared here to make
it a little more pronounced and all
positive
and what we do is we color code this by
whether or not the forcing is larger
than some threshold value we color it
red
and if the forcing is small smaller than
a threshold value we color it white
and recall that when the forcing is not
active the system is really well
described by this linear
excuse me linear kupeman model and when
the forcing is
is active some essential non-linearity
is forcing the system and making
something interesting happen
now what's really fascinating here is
that the system whenever
it's in this quiescent state that the
forcing is inactive
and any time it's about to switch the
forcing jumps up
and so if we zoom in we want to know if
this is actually predictive or not so
this is zooming into a couple of these
field switching events
and you see that it's just doing its
normal fluctuations and then here
it's about to jump uh the fields about
to flip
and what's interesting is i would i
would challenge you if you didn't have
this color coded and you if you didn't
know
if you were just measuring this in time
you might not know when it's about to
flip you might say it's going to flip
here
or you might not know it's going to flip
here this is within the expected
kind of variance of the signal but when
the system is ready to
switch you get a jump in this external
forcing clear as day this
very big signature that says the system
is about to switch
and it's pretty good at predicting it
doesn't it's not 100
but it is pretty good at predicting when
the system is about to switch
this forcing turns on and you can see
from the zoom in that it's actually
quite predictive right
these are you know you're getting a
heads up
that is preceding what you might be
guessing
just by by eyeball
okay so now let's look at the the
measles outbreak data this is a really
neat data set this is you know
actual occurrences of measles outbreaks
binned every two weeks from 1928 to 1964
in new york city and this is actually a
data set that's been well studied in the
context of time delay
uh embedding so sugahara and may have
have
studied this in their seminal paper and
many many since
and this is what the data looks like in
our eigen time delay coordinates
so the steady state where there's no
measles corresponds to the origin
and you essentially find that measles
outbreaks are excursions from the origin
so the system bursts and then comes back
bursts and then comes back and the
bigger the burst the worse the outbreak
okay so this is kind of the outbreak
severity
over here and again you can plot the
same
uh the same model prediction with the
havoc analysis so here you see the
forcing
uh color coded by red it's a little
harder to see because actually this one
stands out it's so large
but you can see that when the forcing is
active
is red you have these big kind of
measles epidemics or outbreaks and
the bigger the forcing the bigger the
outbreak
so what i think is really interesting is
if you zoom in on this this is the worst
outbreak in this time
series and if you zoom in you actually
see that there are a couple little dips
in the in the measurement that could
easily have been false predictions right
here you also see one this is a little
dip it
would be easy for you to say oh no
there's going to be a measles outbreak
because you see that dip
but the forcing didn't say that there's
going to be an outbreak it waited until
right here where it's actually not even
in a dip
and then the forcing kicks on clears day
and says there's going to be a measles
outbreak
and if you zoom in you can actually see
that when this jumps up
it jumps up more for this big measles
outbreak than for the others so you
might actually be able to not only get a
prediction that there's going to be
measles outbreak
but you might also get a prediction of
the severity of the outbreak
based on uh the the this
forcing signal and this is a forcing
signal you can measure right you're
you're collecting data
you're measuring the system so you
actually know what that forcing signal
is now
and so if that forcing signal gets large
you know that you can measure that and
you
can predict that you are likely to go
into
you know once every 30-year measles
outbreak
okay so this is just a short overview
you can download all of the code for
every example
uh on my website and try all of these
yourself
it's really fun one of the things i like
about this is that if you have data
you can plug it in and start analyzing
and building models and building
predictions and gaining insights right
off the bat
so so please download the code try it on
your data try it on this data
thank you very much
you